- I would say in, like,
the pantheon of Super Bowls
Steelers-Cardinals was, like,
one of the greatest
most exciting games I've ever seen.
- Super Bowl 43, yeah.
- You ended that Super Bowl.
So, like, take me through
the play, man.
Like, that s--t was nuts.
- You know, it was, like,
we had a timeout before
and I remember Coach Tomlin
pullin' us out, like
"Woo, we need a big play."
You know, that's the kinda
s--t you see on TV, in a movie.
Like, "Come on, man,
we need a big play from you."
Like, man, I ain't finna make
no big play.
Like, "All right, Coach,
you know I got you."
You know, they got
Larry Fitzgerald
tallest receiver out there
at the time.
Kurt Warner can throw the ball.
- Yeah.
- So the best thing to do
is to stop the ball,
like in basketball.
Stop the guy with the ball.
So I'm rushin',
and Kurt Warner's lookin' at me
so as I went out,
he dipped in, so I dipped out
and I seen Kurt reaching back,
and I just kinda like—
- Superman.
- Supermanned it.
- Yeah.
- Hit the ball out,
sack, forced fumble.
Brett Keisel jumped on the ball.
- There's probably two moments
where the crowd goes nuts, right?
One when you smack it out
and then, like,
the realization afterwards.
- You know what?
It didn't feel real at first.
Going into that game, we felt
like we was gonna win anyways
so I already had my camera
on the sideline.
- What do you mean,
you brought a camera down?
- After halftime,
I snuck it on the field.
- You snuck it on your jersey?
- I snuck it on the field.
- So were you doing, like,
selfies?
- Hell yeah.
I was recording myself.
And I remember Brett Keisel
asking me, said
"LaMarr, man,
you want the football?"
I said, "Nah, man, keep it."
Why in the hell did I say that?
- Yeah, what were you thinking?
- He caught me
at an exciting time.
- Bein' a good teammate.
- Yeah.
And to this day,
I'm still tryin'
to get that damn ball back.
If I ever go to his house,
I'm takin' the ball.
- You gonna steal it?
- Yeah, I'm gonna steal it.
- Brett, Brett,
hide the ball, man.
- I'm stealin' that, for real.
- [Laughing]
- When the Eagles beat the Bears,
I was so excited